this is a production of Cornell
University
there are three sources of fixed
nitrogen used in agriculture the first
in my far the most widely used sources
nitrogen fertilizer derived from the
haber-bosch process the second
biological nitrogen fixation accounts
for about thirty percent of the
agricultural nitrogen globally the third
and least important is a group of
harvested ermine sources such as fish
waste into layin nitrate in theory
organic farmers combine luminous cover
crops with small additions of compost to
maintain soil fertility this works for
some farming systems such as grain
production where biological nitrogen
fixation accounts for the majority of
newly added nitrogen however others such
as most fresh vegetable enterprises rely
on animal based compost as the major
source of nitrogen and are therefore
indirectly dependent on haber-bosch
nitrogen while recycling nutrients is a
fundamental principle of organic
agriculture the use of animal manures
for nitrogen is problematic first there
are consequences for the production
system including nutrient imbalances
excessive soil phosphorus levels
increase weed pressure and greater
vulnerability to environmental nutrient
losses from a broader perspective the
dependence on haber-bosch nitrogen
undermines claims that organic
agriculture is a more sustainable
production system the founders of
organic agriculture got it right when
they prohibited the use of haber-bosch
nitrogen and chose biological nitrogen
fixation as the primary source of new
nitrogen biological nitrogen fixation is
a sustainable solar powered nitrogen
source that promotes soil organic matter
of cruel and restores internal cycling
processes in contrast production of
haber-bosch nitrogen is highly fossil
fuel dependent and significant
greenhouse gas emissions result from
this process the amount of haber-bosch
nitrogen used is massive global usage
for this year's forecast to be 116
million metric tons of nitrogen during
this five minute presentation 1100
tons of new nitrogen will be produced
furthermore haber-bosch nitrogen is
extremely inefficient on average half of
this nitrogen is lost to the biosphere
leading to eutrophication and greenhouse
gas emissions it's likely that we've
already altered the global nitrogen
cycle to a point where the extra
nitrogen is driving irreversible changes
in the biosphere beyond these
environmental concerns new knowledge
about the role of the plant microbiome
the microbial communities associated
with plants points the way towards
sustainable nutrient management
strategies plants and their micro biomes
have been co-evolving for seven hundred
million years and greater understanding
of the role of the plant microbiome has
overturned our view of plant nutrient
acquisition and biological soil
processes decomposition is a case in
point until recently decomposition has
been viewed as a microbially governed
process occurring in bulk soil
independent of plants a view compatible
with the strategy of delivering
available nitrogen directly to crops
it's now clear that a continuum of plant
microbial associations govern
decomposition plants can stimulate
decomposition by providing carbon to
decomposers in exchange for nitrogen and
other nutrients the carbon provides
energy to subsidize the cost of
expensive XO enzymes decomposers must
make to free nitrogen this exchange of
carbon for nutrients in the rhizosphere
provides an efficient means for
delivering nitrogen to plants so much so
that even under optimal fertilizer
management regimes crops still rely
heavily on soil organic nitrogen pools
reflecting their coevolution with
decomposers for example and
conventionally managed grains receiving
recommended fertilizer rates fertilizer
nitrogen accounts for less than forty
percent of the night
taken up by the crops to promote
sustainable nitrogen management we need
to use systems thinking that includes
ecological and evolutionary mechanisms
as well as IRA cultural knowledge we
need to manage nitrogen and carbon
together and build soil nutrient
reserves so that crops can take
advantage of mechanisms developed in the
course of coevolution with microbes this
approach will lead to a cascade of
beneficial shifts in agroecosystems that
support sustainable food production
organic certification rules need to be
modified to promote biological nitrogen
fixation is the primary nitrogen source
in organic systems the time is right to
begin weaning organic agriculture away
from haber-bosch nitrogen dependence